what's up guys bang-bang-bang
lunch money coming to you every day noon
ish before noon afternoon right at noon
or 5:00 p.m. depending on if we have our
[ __ ] together or not while Wall Street's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get our lunch money right the
ever beautiful miss Polina today she
looks like an angel I guess no prisoner
outfit no lunch
Oh the Apple watch saga is resolved do
you want to tell me why your Apple watch
got ruined okay
I had an Apple watch and I went swimming
in it and by the way I did everything
Apple says to do before you get in a
pool and expose it to water except that
was a total lie because I did a few laps
in it counted them and and suddenly it
was like bye sorry in a blink it was
dead well some more people like me we
just never get in the pool with your
watch now why do you need to come you're
like apple claims of that is a feature
and I wanted to try it and I was
exercising in a pool trust no one
questioned everything we got your new
watch for ready to rock and roll what's
going on with unemployment today
unemployment sad everything sad today
clean up warning warning warning Lena
has hot taste today she has not been in
a good mood all day it thankfully is not
because of anything I did she just has
hot takes about the economy we're gonna
get to this what's going on with
unemployment I'm not what's going on
unemployed people are losing their jobs
and the government is doing nothing 4.4
million Americans file unemployment
claims last week the report hit this
morning that means twenty six point five
million Americans have filed for
unemployment in the last five weeks 26
million 500,000 people have lost their
jobs in the last five weeks and filed
for unemployment if you add in five you
know five of the 26.5 lines okay well
there's only twenty six point four nine
five nine nine nine or something like
that
five is still a lot five is a lot
alright so what that does is if you add
in the five point eight million
Americans at the end of February who are
unemployed that means that
up to 32 million Americans right now
over 32 million Americans do not have a
job
two ways to think about that that is
close to 20 percent unemployment of the
labor force right hundred 65 million
Americans in the labor force not
including people two older children etc
or another way to look at it is that is
10 percent right around 10 percent of
the u.s. population every man woman and
child 10 percent of them have no job
regardless of if you're one years old in
the workforce or out of the workforce it
is nuts
it says this would be the highest level
the unemployment rate of 20.6% since
1934 ok well so go back to the Great
Depression which is in the 1930s and the
Great Depression as you guys remember
3.5% is in 1929 with a Great Depression
started 3.5% was a historic low we were
just at 3.1 percent in February of this
year which was a historic low so very
similar it took two years to go from 3.5
percent to over 15 percent maybe five
weeks five weeks exactly so not good
the second thing is remember that the
unemployment rate only shows those
people who actually filed right and so
what's likely to happen is the reports
gonna come in somewhere between 12 to 13
percent is gonna be the official
unemployment rate that's because not
everyone is still getting unemployment
who previously filed in prior weeks
it also doesn't include gig workers
freelancers self-employed people who are
trying to file but can't file or people
who have lost wages meaning that their
actual payment has been reduced or
they've lost hours at work so the real
unemployment rate is closer to 20
percent you're upset why can't I well
thanks
okay we got two months of this other
than printing money in doing press
conferences and like doing nothing the
government has done very little to help
people and if it was me pulling up for
president if it was me I would not sleep
until I was working with the public
sector the private sector etc took to
get tests out and to figure out what the
hell is actually going
and take quick lick measures to have a
plan to one contain the virus but also
make sure that people have Houdini of
course well that's why you're starting
to see now see now you're starting to
see the light I've been saying this for
weeks now which is people are not going
to let this happen people are not gonna
sit around and have the government
mandate shut down some businesses money
plus million people lose their jobs and
have the government go on television and
say don't worry we got it under control
everything's good to go under control
and they're not even trying to say they
have it under control their only plan is
stay at home indefinitely that's not a
plan of course not in what happened with
Cuomo let's talk about who says one more
time the domestic violence does not
equal death he can come call me all
right he gave a speech recently and in
it he somebody asked him yes there are
people dying from this but what about
the drug addiction the domestic violence
reporter asked whether we what he was
gonna do when we started seeing deaths
from the economic hardship and he said
economic hardship does not equal death
emotional stress does not equal death
and domestic violence is increasing it's
very bad but it is not death and I can
tell I can point him to a statistic oh
did you go do research you read the
Internet okay big time by the way did
you guys see that I pulled up my little
Starbucks we went outside
don't tell anybody we went outside today
all right go ahead I'm headed to the CDC
in 2017 half of all female homicide
victims are killed by their intimate
partners so there you go Cuomo next time
you want to say I hear your facts
can you move on no the long story short
is unemployment is really bad the
government hasn't done enough to get
people the relief that they need there's
unemployment insurance you can file for
but on top of that the payroll
protection program one of the big issues
is only 3% of all applicants have been
processed approved and funded there's
97% of small businesses in the United
States there have filed for this that
don't have the capital we still do not
have a refreshment of that
money they're supposed to put 310
billion dollars into new funds for the
PPP program unfortunately though that
will not be enough is probably only
going to cover about 10% the only
solution to solving this problem and I
continue to pound the table on this over
and over and over again we have to open
up the economy we can do it safely we
can do it intelligently but we have to
open the economy that is the only way to
get people back to work and to get
people in a safe financial position we
at least need a plan because right now
people feel powerless and hopeless but
the regular person feels so much anxiety
and they're the only thing that they're
being told is you're gonna be home
indefinitely and we don't know when
you're gonna have a problem true anyway
are you on Team open the economy safely
I don't team let's have a plan let's
test people and let's start to reopen
the economy safely bang-bang leave a
comment and let us know what your plan
is to open the economy safely move on to
magically talk about maybe not so
intelligent people who made a mistake
that was really easy to seek up so so
can you just in your tech speak explain
what magically magically basically is
this idea that you're going to take a
pair of goggles you're gonna put them on
and magically you're gonna get a bunch
of 3d rendering augmented reality all
this kind of stuff the technology seems
super super cool right they've done
everything from like you could literally
rather than look at a traditional x-ray
or or some sort of medical scan you
could see like the heart palpating you
didn't know I knew that word palpating
right there I think it is but maybe not
and no palpating you can google it I
read the internet but also you can do
all kinds of augmented reality except
for a short story is that they raised
what 2.6 billion dollars what did you
just wake up cause I read the Internet I
know these things they raise 2.6 billion
here they raise 2.6 billion dollars and
basically they have no product to show
so they do have eventually they
eventually release the product not
really for consumers
kind of for enterprise but for a very
long time they have no product to show
the public and they kept raising
billions of dollars in venture capital
this story is like three weeks ago they
were like hey we're gonna sell our
business for ten billion dollars so
we're actually amount of capital that
they were gonna that they raised and
then nobody's everyone was like what
your company's not worth ten billion
dollars and now all of a sudden do it oh
just kidding we're gonna lay off fifty
percent of our staff a thousand
employees and they're what pivoting long
story short is the market called
[ __ ] on magically I was tell them
what um what you did when you wrote when
you wrote about magically when you said
that this is you have questions yeah I
had questions
she wrote a whole write-up about magic
leap and their fundraising and she's
like look when is people when have
people successfully raised a ton of
money without a product and been and
actually had it work out so you called
me you called the magic leap fall in
2017 called it all right what's going on
bill really speaking up one of the best
investors of all time
go girlie benchmark capital he's been
investing for twenty years and finally
he was one of the earliest investors in
uber and if you guys remember he was
also the one who pushed for the push out
of Travis Cod all right I don't think
you could say bill Gurley was they call
me one benchmark before so Bill Gurley
is a venture capitalist true but Bill
Gurley is an investor at benchmark
capital benchmark as many joke around
and say literally the name is true they
are the benchmark they're one of the
best investors in Silicon Valley bill
girl he's been a big part of that over
the last 20 years he used to sit on the
board of Ober he definitely was involved
in the pushing out of Travis kalanick
from uber as a CEO but he now is not
going to be participating in the next
fund that benchmark raises there's lots
of questions does that mean Bill
grilli's retiring tomorrow probably not
it just means that he's not signing up
for the next 10 or 15 years of investing
he's basically gonna ride out what he's
already done
towards the end of his career yeah so
basically benchmark reached out some
limited partners to raise 425 million
for its tenth adventure pun so bill will
not be part of that but it sounds like
he's gonna continue to be very involved
one of my favorite parts about benchmark
to things that are my favorite everybody
who joins is a partner yeah so everyone
has an equal sticker on the table so
let's say that there was five people at
benchmark when they go to hire a sixth
person when the sixth person joins they
all get an equal split and so it's
really cool how they they really respect
each other they really have kind of a
team mentality and the second thing is
in an age where all these firms went out
and raised massive funds they were
raising billions of dollars benchmarks a
super super discipline and they
continued to raise somewhere between 400
and 500 million dollars in most cases
time and time again they never got
attracted so let's go raise billions of
dollars it's because they believe that's
the amount of money per fund that they
can invest and drive returns for
investors and they've done that at the
highest level year after year after year
for decades now there was literally just
benchmark and address
there's no look at our investments
they're just very like low-key and they
they they do their work and they did
great returns they're fantastic people
Bill Curley you it's Bill Goldy is Bill
Gurley more like Scottie Pippen or
Michael Jordan he's I think he's Michael
Jordan
yeah like everyone just knows he's the
goat I'm so team Scottie eat all right
what's going on with the gap year gap
you're a bunch of high school students
that are graduating this year choosing
to take a gap year instead of going to
college because I mean are they choosing
or are they being forced to no it says
they're choosing because people are
saying like for example this girl said
you always hear people say a friends
from college or the ones you have for
life I don't want to miss out on that so
they don't want to go and not have the
physical in-person experience this kind
of feels like if you were in the ATM and
I walked up with
gun and put it to your head said give me
your money and then I told the court she
chose to give me the money but why do
you think that well where are they gonna
go to school schools are getting
canceled and everything canceled you can
still enroll online yeah but that but
the whole point of college for these
kids is to go and actually be there in
person so you can't go in person they're
basically being forced if that was the
whole value to your being forced not to
go because it's an online education now
so I don't know exactly what this is but
the president and CEO of command
education in New York said typically
only two to three students want to take
a gap year this year it's about 75% he
said of the college-bound students and
Families he works with I mean in corona
time anything goes your dislike throw
caution to the wind whatever a pandemic
baby I kind of did did you well would
you have kind kind of done I my entire I
got pulled out of college to go to the
law it was a gap here trust me I missed
three semesters and was run around with
a gun in my hand it was like everyone
knows that you can go study abroad like
semester at sea or you go to some
foreign land and have all this fun go
drinking with your friends whatever and
yeah and I just say yeah I did this
study abroad too I just studied abroad
in Iraq so would you
Google Maps would go ahead tell the
story I know you think I was asking him
like tell me about Renu about like where
you would drive and the base we just
watched some war movie and I love a good
war movie and so I asked what the name
of the town where you're based was and
we went on Google Maps so I was like why
isn't it letting me zoom in and do that
um the the person may not the street man
on the street the street view Street you
and I touch I was like this isn't
working and it was all blurry and he was
like yeah of course we was not going to
let you see satellite photos of the US
military bases you kind of they just
didn't let you do Street View I'm
guessing Google cars are driving around
in there they're not you know all right
what's going on with zoom fatigue so
apparently people are getting fatigued
by zoom people are song
people thought this [ __ ] listen you do
seem like 84 times a day and a my
fatigue no that's because I'm not can
this be turned into a phone call and
said I don't feel it I like to pace when
I'm on the phone just like you I don't
like sitting here and like staring at a
camera do you want to turn the video on
if they do is in yeah but they typically
if they want to do a zoom they want to
see your face and they'll be like you
really do we have to and they're like
what I do just tell me you're in a
coffee shop with bad Wi-Fi you need to
shut the video off so they're the calls
quality there's no coffee shop that's
the point it's just a nice way of saying
I'm not turning on my video yeah do you
do have you ever done a zoom call where
you are like professional laptop but
download I actually have pants on today
big big surprise no sweat pants shorts
today I actually have pants on cuz we
went outside we went and got a little
bit of Starbucks Shh gotta do mobile
ordering they won't let you walk in the
store but I'm a little mask on awesome
cranking down the shirt looks like safe
people like a healthy person trying to
take care of the world it's like you
know it's kind of like a the mask is
there to protect other people from you I
hate I want everybody to be protected
and safe I just don't want to listen to
politicians and their stupid big egos
power jockeying to get elected and not
care about me
I feel like the longer that we've been
doing lunch money the more that point is
starting to see the light she's starting
to realize how much [ __ ] is out
there I'm just sad and upset that it
seems like politicians care more about
power than they do about their people of
course welcome to the world wars like if
you're elected to office you should I
don't know they're all the same they're
all the same doesn't matter what side of
the aisle they're on they're all the
same all they are doing is they're doing
what they think they have to do whatever
I tell you the beginning $1200 is a
bride that's not to help the people that
was a bribe to keep social unrest at bay
their payroll protection program they
literally gave money out of the PPP 275
publicly traded companies I know
do you think those
come bees me the money maybe but it's
not for them it's not for them they gave
money they earmark specific funds in the
stimulus package for universities
universities have had two things happen
one actually their expenses in many
cases have gone down and two is most of
the revenue has actually stayed constant
universities are losing a bunch of money
how I don't remember I read a lot this
morning know the expenses are going down
because they fired a bunch of employees
you do that but the whole point is
you're now starting to see in a time of
crisis people get exposed the virus has
exposed the shams in the world I'm
telling you guys this for weeks now the
virus has exposed the shame there's just
a bunch of incompetent people at every
level and if you voted for a pony you
know this wouldn't happen there's zero
chance you're running for anything why
why would you want that life I don't
want that life but I care about people
are you good are you announcing with a
mayoral run ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls please send help
yeah bang bang well Wall Street's trying
to get rich through us just trying to
get a lunch money right I want to make
sure Luke it's know what what they need
to be crying uh yes she's my sitter she
was like an angel today looks beautiful
as always even smarter than that she
lets on and I appreciate guys all
watching this big ass today go leave a
comment I've been told if you like the
video or like actually hit the little
like button or go share it and make sure
that you're subscribed the views will
keep going up supposedly if we get more
views it means that more people are
watching who knows of YouTube telling
the truth or not but I appreciate
everyone watching I like I like
personally I just like the people who
are you watching I don't care about
people who don't watch we'll see you
guys tomorrow